what's going on guys bang bang this was
a big week for Bitcoin Bitcoin has
started q1 of 2023 on an absolute rocket
it's up almost 70 percent to start
the year it's one of the best performing
assets across all financial markets we
also don't just see the price increasing
we continue to see bitcoin's hash rate
hit all-time highs week after week after
week and this past week was no different
the Bitcoin network has never been more
decentralized or secure than it is today
on top of that Michael Saylor bought
another 150 million dollars worth of
bitcoin now closing in on owning one
percent of the total Supply
not only is Michael sailor buy but it
appears that people around the world
continue to buy Bitcoin as well we have
seen wallets with more than zero Bitcoin
in it grow at its fastest Pace since
2021 that means that people around the
world are dollar cost averaging into an
asset now one of the reasons why people
maybe dollar cost averaging into Bitcoin
is because they're seeking safety we
have seen the Legacy Financial system
that people are plowing hundreds of
billions of dollars into Cash funds
things like money market funds and that
is one of the fastest rates since
covid-19 first hit the United States
now as investors seek safety in the
traditional Financial system they want
dollars and they put their money into
those cash funds but in the digital
Financial system people want the digital
Reserve asset which is Bitcoin and
that's where they seek safety that's a
huge reason why we continue to see
bitcoin's price increase and see that 70
performance to start the year now not
only are people seeking safety but also
there are many countries around the
world that are all diversifying away
from the dollar we saw China and Brazil
reach an agreement this week where they
will now start to settle bilateral trade
in their own National currencies that is
a move away from US Dollars and it also
is joined by countries like Saudi Arabia
and others who are choosing to do
similar things now I don't think the US
dollar is actually going to fall out of
popularity and yes there are countries
that want to diversify away but over the
last couple of decades people have
talked about this time and again every
couple of years but the US dollar
Remains the global Reserve currency is
backed by the strongest military in the
world and it continues to be the
currency that most people choose to
settle their transactions with even when
it is two large countries conducting
that bilateral trade now in the new
system in this digital Financial system
we've seen Bitcoin serving as that
Reserve currency although many people in
the Bitcoin Community believe that the
dollar will fail and that Bitcoin will
be the beneficiary I don't know if we
can really say that in the short term it
is much more likely in my opinion that
Bitcoin and the dollar will both
strengthen in the short term as many
other weak Fiat currencies fall the
dollar will strengthen and many people
who are seeking something outside of the
system will help Bitcoin strengthen as
well if Bitcoin and the dollar
strengthened in the short to medium term
that may be the best case scenario but
over the long term the dollar is
guaranteed to be devalued and every fiat
currency continues to lose purchasing
power and so I do believe that Bitcoin
will continue to rise for decades to
come in popularity in adoption and
ultimately in US dollar price now I
don't have some sort of magic eight ball
I can't tell you the future but what I
can tell you is that right now Bitcoin
is performing incredibly well and at the
same time that people are seeking
dollars they're also seeking Bitcoin and
that's a data point that we should keep
paying attention to as we get deeper
into the 2023 Year hope all of you had a
great week hope you enjoyed this update
and I'll see you all next Saturday